hi I'm Brett hi I'm Jason we are
redrawing cartoon characters from
memories specifically Pokemon can I make
a confession I've never seen Pokemon oh
my god I'm old Jackie you don't look a
day over my age okay I got this I don't
got I got the poor in Vaporeon it's part
it's an eeveelution use the water stone
to get it from Eevee I have no idea what
any of those words mean
he is spiky hair yeah yes baby the
update is look I feel like every few
years they do generations you sure
remember like the og look give me some
clues to the construction okay first of
all blue it's blue it's a water pokemon
okay so it's gonna be like fish features
but not like really hardcore is it like
a fish man no so this Pokemon is closely
resembles like a cat he's like a cat
electro cat it's a mouse house but as
we've discussed they don't ever look
like the animals they're based on well I
was starting with like a kind of basic
cat construction but it's kind of
turning more into a dog there's nothing
wrong with a little flair of your own I
was one of those kids who like loved
drawing animals so much so I drew all of
the Pokemon I don't think I've ever
drawn yeah she cared about and it's like
he was just a vehicle first to see cute
pokémon I think I went in my head in the
electro tail yes right I don't even know
if I got that right I think that's what
it looks like I think I'm drawing a
snowman with electro tail actually how
do you get the baseball hat to not cover
the face I'm gonna make characters don't
have like deceptively big heads I know
the like what you're generally supposed
to do in Pokemon is the guy's name is
ash he collects Pokemon in order to
battle against other Pokemon collectors
and they use come on this is this is
just cultural osmosis here like I don't
this is just what I know from being a
person in the world I think of his body
I guess maybe it's like a sack I don't
know it's kind of got like a slim frame
it's kind of slippery it's not like fat
I don't know
the sack of flour yeah he's a sec fire
anyway when you beat someone in Pokemon
you don't get their Pokemon you don't
you just get there you get the bragging
rights what happens that's it when you
defeat someone in chess you don't get
their chess pieces you just get bragging
don't oh my god oh my god I love Pokemon
because it's just you could just go as a
child and explore the world and your
mom's just like okay I think that hat is
red and white penny is like a green
symbol on it so Vaporeon is the evolved
form of Eevee okay and Eevee is this
Pokemon that's really popular because
one Phoebe's adorable okay Pikachu is an
electric pokemon the evolved form of
Pichu and the pre-evolved form of right
you got put goop against him and two
because Evie's like one of the only
pokemons that like has like multiple
evolutions fun fact Pikachu can learn
the move surf so this is not an
inaccurate thing I'm driving doesn't he
just say Pikachu could you could you do
it for us Jason do you know disco there
we go there you go
that goes my expenses my dollars on
Pikachu alright well if these this extra
time I have I'm gonna start drawing Ryan
or Ryan Reynolds Pikachu oh sure in what
situation would you use a Victorian
against fire type Pokemon be not against
an electric-type pokémon no I would yeah
so ash basically just is on this
never-ending quest to be the ultimate
Pokemon master but he's a fool who only
catches like five pokemon and he catches
like the worst pokemon yeah I am drawing
something very interesting but it is
most definitely not a Vaporeon I kind of
wish again mine was more simplified and
cuter cuz I feel like I'm gonna see what
it really looks like and I'm gonna be
like you know what all that time I spent
making fun of you should have been me
practicing how to humble myself yea
Glass Houses check ya Glass Houses
hubris all that I give him an A for
Alvin like broken hearts okay I'm done
that there's no pose it's just a like it
looks like he's Flat Stanley but oh my
god his arm is so long I'm so that's it
whatever done
don't stop that's pretty darn accurate
with the cartoon Pikachu I'm not gonna
lie pretty embarrassing if I was like
way off the mark with this one I think
if you look at mine you can say that is
Pikachu yeah I don't think I got the I
guess the shape of Pikachu right at all
I mean it's not a good drawing but I
think that it is ash I think I got like
the feel of him like like a fan art
drawing of him but I oh I did him so
dirty on the outfit I'm so sorry
I love Pokemon I think I did pretty okay
if it doesn't look like beforehand I
think the drawings really cute so - both
ah
not Vaporeon but also not quite really a
great drawing well you know what it
really do be like that they'd be like
that sometimes it's true it's true oh I
actually did kind of better than I
thought I would you know I tried my best
and that's all that matters oh yeah oh
come on
spitting image looks exactly like him I
should have given his eyes a little bit
more character but yeah I think it still
looks like a Pikachu oh I think I didn't
do horrible okay how am I supposed to
like remember all the like eeveelutions
you know so if anyone has anything to
say to me don't because I'm really
sensitive it's gonna hurt my feeling
mine is not correct at all ah but it's a
lot closer than I thought it was going
to be you got the shirt and the spirit
do it better his best it looks so
comfortable they gave them a puffy sort
of Marty McFly vests yours is definitely
a little bit more I think accurate yours
looks like water Garfield I love it if
Garfield was a water type that's what
this would look like cuz you said it's
like a water cat what I can't when I
think water cat I think well Garfield
and also give the bus - yeah
I must say this Pikachu's pretty
accurate yours is actually really close
I feel like it's it's it's like it's I
forgot the whole head nod do you even
remembered like the the bifurcated tail
we like both remembered similar things
yeah pants look like this and he
definitely has like this going on but I
like he's got like battle scars all over
him like these brown marks I'd rather
these needs to draw I'm gonna do some
hatching and lining you are much closer
I think yours is good for someone who
never watched or thank God into Pokemon
from the very bad description I gave you
you really made it work I really love
the antenna right it's I just don't
understand do fish have antennae some do
I know more about Pokemon that I do fish
right yeah put us together
yeah put us together we're the perfect
person we would be water gym leaders I
don't know what that means but I'm in
that means we're the best at water
pokemon kind of there's more than gym
leaders there's a lot of them there's
the Elite Four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]